entrepreneurs like elon musk know
something about business that keeps them
ahead of the competition let's go
through his three-step formula by
analyzing tesla and spacex a little
later on we'll actually read some
internal company emails because elon
does some pretty interesting things
inside his businesses but first we need
to talk about something that's often
overlooked which takes us to step number
one elon has a system for getting
businesses off the ground what i've
noticed about some of the best
entrepreneurs in the world is that they
are incredible at identifying big
opportunities someone like elon is
constantly thinking of ideas his real
skill is being able to filter through
them and pick the one that has the best
chance of getting funding and attracting
talent and the good news is that there's
a bit of a system to this i've noticed
that the businesses that elon
prioritizes have to pass four main
criteria before he starts them the first
thing is all of elon's businesses have a
large addressable market it shouldn't be
a surprise that the biggest companies
tend to operate in the biggest markets
small markets are great for building
lifestyle businesses but elon wants more
the global car market is worth nearly
four trillion dollars so it's no
surprise that there are 40 car companies
worth more than 1 billion dollars the
second thing is that elon's companies
tend to operate in blue ocean markets
even though there are dozens of large
car companies there weren't any
manufacturers really taking electric
cars seriously when he started working
on tesla it's easy to attract talent and
capital when you're the only company
working on a new technology the same
thing is true for spacex reusable
rockets were heavily doubted for years
before elon and his team got them to
work but by taking a unique approach
from day one he basically had no real
competition who is your competition we
have no serious competition elon's
companies also build on his previous
skills in college he studied economics
and physics so when he built paypal he
was well equipped to understand the
economic problems in front of him then
when he started spacex he had no
experience in the aerospace industry but
he had managed a team of engineers
before and could leverage his physics
knowledge finally elon always stresses
the importance of building a world-class
team we'll cover some of the recruiting
tactics elon uses later in the video if
you look at any of elon's companies they
all follow these four criteria but now
it's time for the really interesting
parts because ideas are useless without
execution which takes us on to step
number two elon builds for exponential
growth i heard something about elon
recently that really surprised me and
it's one of the main reasons i wanted to
make this video in the first place
despite being worth over 200 billion
dollars elon still has a regular 10 pm
meeting on raptor engine design at
spacex now i've worked with plenty of
billion dollar company founders and
trust me this is very rare so why does
elon do this to himself well let's take
a listen to elon explaining why he is so
dedicated to spacex when you had that
third failure in a row
did you think
i need to pack this in never
why not
i don't ever give up
i'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated okay so
elon's really hyped up his ability to
consistently raise the stakes financial
markets as we've discussed many times
before reward companies who can
consistently outperform expectations so
let's take a look at the number of
vehicles tesla was able to deliver over
the past 10 years
as you can see the growth in tesla
deliveries is almost perfectly
exponential but this wasn't just luck
elon had a strategy to deliver better
and better results each year he outlined
this in his secret plan back in 2006 the
goal was simple tesla would build a
high-end sports car to fund the
development of a sporty four-door family
car which in turn would fund an even
cheaper third model exponential growth
is all about timing elon focuses on the
product first the team will iterate on
the core design until it's ready to
produce then there's a big marketing
announcement that generates a wave of
hype he then channels all this hype into
pre-orders for the new vehicle this
helps generate cash for the business but
also validates demand and justifies
additional investment finally when the
cash is in the bank tesla can break
ground on a new manufacturing facility
to ramp up production building new
manufacturing capacity is extremely
risky but elon succeeds by using a
proven structure product customer demand
investment many companies fail because
they get this order wrong they raise too
much money too soon or they try to scale
a product that doesn't have proven
demand if you look a bit closer at the
tesla data you'll notice that model s
deliveries actually plateaued pretty
early on elon was already thinking ahead
though and had a plan to continue the
exponential growth technology innovation
usually follows an s-curve when a new
product like the tesla model s comes
along it takes off very quickly but then
it reaches maturity then a new
innovation window opens and a new
product can take off if it's better elon
is able to look into the future and
anticipate what technologies will
disrupt tesla and then start building
those technologies before the
competition can take over after the
model s proved that electric cars could
become popular he had to follow up with
a cheaper option in order to hit that
next part of the exponential curve and
elon followed this same strategy at
spacex and carefully staged investments
based on successful tests it took three
years for spacex to launch their first
falcon 1 rocket and it exploded after
just 33 seconds of flight progress was
slow at first and the second launch
didn't happen until 2007 but elon kept
pushing things forward at each stage the
team learned valuable lessons and
improved their technology that
eventually led spacex to win a massive
contract from nasa to deliver supplies
to the international space station over
the past 10 years spacex has steadily
increased capacity every year and is now
experiencing the exponential growth that
elon planned out when the company
started growing extremely quickly
creates lots of problems though as tesla
fought to double the amount of cars they
delivered each year it's easy to forget
about what was going on inside the
company to make that happen as a company
scales offices will get bigger more
people will get hired and everything
gets more complex that's why elon
insists that tesla employees always work
in the actual tesla offices in an email
earlier this year elon said that
everyone at tesla is required to spend a
minimum of 40 hours a week in the office
his goal is to keep people in sync with
each other and consistently push for
better results in the early days of
tesla elon lived in the factory and
slept on the floor also he could
constantly be in tune with production
and identify any blockers to growth this
type of decisive management doesn't work
unless your team is fully aligned with
your mission but elon has made it clear
that he's not just working for a quick
buck his companies are the type of place
where you can spend your entire career
and always be working on something new
to really build a massive company you
need to set yourself up for exponential
growth but for elon's formula there's
still a vital part that's missing which
takes us on to the next step elon
maximizes terminal value elon knows that
all his effort up to this point would be
useless if he doesn't capture as much of
the market as possible after all
exponential growth always comes to an
end when we see an exponential curve in
the real world we are actually seeing
just the beginning of a logistic curve
at some point the growth rate will start
to decline and eventually plateau you
can't just project out tesla deliveries
exponentially forever if you did you'd
eventually end up estimating that tesla
would sell more cars every year than
human beings on the planet which is just
impossible but elon recognizes that
hyper growth will inevitably end and he
plans for this first by operating in
only the largest markets his growth
curves will naturally have very high end
points tesla might eventually plateau
but at least it will still be operating
in one of the largest industries in the
world elon doesn't stop there though he
consistently creates opportunities to
increase the size of the market he's
going after with tesla that means
building self-driving car technology and
eventually humanoid robots as well the
timelines on these projects are
constantly slipping but that actually
doesn't matter as much as people think
as long as these technologies eventually
become valuable tesla will be able to
capitalize on them the same is true for
spacex where elon realized that the
market for launching rockets just wasn't
big enough so he had to build starlink
the aerospace industry is clearly
extremely important but the entire
launch market is just 8 billion
so it wouldn't be easy for elon to reach
his goals by sticking exclusively to
launches but the market for internet
connectivity is much bigger globally
broadband internet is worth over one
trillion dollars so by expanding his
business into this new area elon has
been able to justify additional
investment in spacex and ultimately
reshape the aerospace industry in the
process the impact of starlink on elon's
plans really can't be underestimated so
if you want to understand how elon is
strategizing for the next decade of
space exploration you have to watch this
video about how spacex makes money next
thanks for watching